[Music]
i don't like anyone listening to the
songs that i write
ever they're for me
little voice was the idea of wanting to
return to this phase in my life when i
was in my early 20s i had to
embody this idea of trusting my own
voice
i just don't have that thing what's your
feeling now use it gonna make a great
song
i think what's interesting about sarah's
work is they were really inspired by
very small personal things that were
happening in her life and that really
interested me on a writing level
to have a show where music is at the
core of it was a wonderful thing because
the music was informing the story as
much as the story was informing the
music you're a great songwriter tell
them what inspired
them i really loved getting to know
brittany through the music of the show
i grew up playing piano so i had the
basic skills but sarah gave great advice
when it comes to singing she taught me
how to play guitar i started playing
things i never thought i could play when
we started singing together i think
that's when we realized we have a lot of
musical chemistry
she came with such a spirit of
collaboration that's such an element of
who bess
is as my dad always said sometimes you
just got to do it for the love of it
sarah talked about new york as being the
kind of heartbeat of the show
it's a place that is just full with
opportunity you're hearing songs
everywhere
from the subway buskers to people in the
park the sounds and the rhythms of the
city are so
alive and vital it certainly was a huge
part of my musical journey
give you some swag
you